FELIPE HOFFA: What can you
do with the election data?
There is a very big
process going on.
And I'm really passionate
about sharing this.
I'm also super happy
to be here with Jordan.
Jordan is one of the BigQuery
team founder members.
JORDAN TIGANI: No,
I just, I think
that it's really
important to understand
what's going on in government,
and with elections.
And I'm really
excited that we're
able to use technology
that I work on
in order to enable people to
do these important things.
So I'm not just excited that
people are using my technology.
I'm excited that
people are going
to be able to use
it to do things
that will change the world.
FELIPE HOFFA: So please
take these tools.
Bring them to your companies.
Bring them to whatever
are your challenges.
And also use them for good.
Use them for civic purposes.
So let's briefly review
technology in the US elections.
JORDAN TIGANI: Thanks, Felipe.
So in 2004, this was really the
first US presidential election,
in which technology played
a played a big impact.
And I don't know if you
remember Howard Dean.
Howard Dean was a
governor of a small state,
not very well known.
But he was getting
massive amounts
of small online donations.
And this really kind of
caused people to wake
up to the idea of using
the internet for elections.
Now I have Howard Dean
versus Howard Dean
because Howard Dean
also sort of died
by technology in the election.
On January 19, he
was giving a speech
after one of the primaries.
And he emitted this sort
of high pitched squeal.
And these two seconds
of squeal then
became a viral video that was
replayed over and over again
across the networks
and on YouTube.
And this really kind
of made him-- there's
nothing worse for a
candidate than being
made to look foolish.
And this sort of
torpedoed his campaign.
So we see also the positive
sides and the negative sides
of technology in elections.
Now if you fast
forward to 2012, you
could argue that it was
Obama versus Romney.
And you could argue
that Obama won.
But is really the big
data nerd election.
Each candidate's campaign team
had big data analysis systems
that were named after whales.
And it turned out that the Obama
team's whales crushed Romney's.
They had software that allowed
them to do things like figure
out how to get
people to the polls,
how to buy media and spend
less, sort of all these areas.
Where on the Romney side,
basically, on election day,
it sort of fizzled.
So it was really kind
of a resounding victory,
regardless of which
candidate you liked,
it was a resounding victory
for the nerd teams that won.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
what we're going
to do today matters a lot.
You can go back to when
the other Clinton was
elected to be president.
There was no internet.
Then, for Bush we saw
ads on the internet.
Then Obama started doing
the first A/B testings
on a political campaign.
And now, four years ago,
we had the whales battling
And today I have some
challenges for Jordan.
And we're going to use some
pretty interesting big data
sets.
If you know Twitter, they
allowed us to use their data.
We are ingesting
this in real time.
JORDAN TIGANI: We also have
the federal election campaign
data set.
The US government has a website
of every campaign donation
given to the candidates
and also what they're
spending their money on.
FELIPE HOFFA: What
can we learn from it?
Next, this data set,
it's a little raw.
So we have our
friends at OpenSecret
that have taken this data,
they have cleaned it up,
and they've made it available
under an open data license.
So we're going to
be using that, too.
JORDAN TIGANI: We also
have every Reddit comment
since 2007, just to give
sort of a less official,
but perhaps just as
enlightening vision of what's
happening with the candidates.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, I have to
thank Jason Baumgardner that
has been collecting and making
these comments available.
And we're going
to have fun there.
Wikipedia, that's a
lot of page views.
Around the 50 billion
page views a month.
What can we see there?
That's part of the
challenge today.
JORDAN TIGANI: And
this is just one table
that's half a terabyte.
We have basically-- this
is just one month's worth.
And we're going to be analyzing
considerably more than that.
FELIPE HOFFA: GDELT, all of the
news in the world, everything
that is happening, collected
by Kalev Leetaru starting
30 years ago until
15 minutes ago,
more than 300 million events.
That's also in our tables.
JORDAN TIGANI: All right,
I guess, before we start,
I want to just provide
a little editorial note.
We're going to show a
lot of visualizations.
We're going to
show a lot of data.
We, Felipe and I,
may be partisan.
But we're not trying to
show anything partisan here.
We're just trying
to show the data.
But you guys certainly
have ideas, and things
that you'd like to show.
We're trying to kind of inspire.
You guys can take the types
of things that we're doing,
and then go off, and make
a persuasive argument.
But we're going to try to just
let the data speak for itself
today.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
Someone told me not to
speak about politics.
I think we will
data-speak about politics.
Let's start.
Let's start with money.
JORDAN TIGANI: Sounds good.
FELIPE HOFFA: What tool
are we going to use today?
JORDAN TIGANI: So I
work on Google BigQuery.
I know BigQuery really well.
And I think BigQuery is great
for analyzing election data.
But if you're not familiar
with Google BigQuery,
it's a big data SQL query
engine that you don't
have to spin up any instances.
It's just all the data is there.
And one of the things that's
under appreciated about it,
and we're going
to leverage today,
is that it's one
global namespace.
So you can join any two tables
against any other table.
FELIPE HOFFA: And it's
a really, really fast.
And it connects with
different tools.
We're going to start
with Re:dash to run some
visualizations.
So my first challenge
for you, Jordan,
is, can you show
me how much money
are the candidates
getting this year?
JORDAN TIGANI: All right, well,
so the first visualization I
have, and I'm going to
use Re:dash for this.
And I'm going to go over the
OpenSecrets individual campaign
donations dataset here.
And we're joining it
with the candidates.
We're filtering by codes
that we don't care about.
And since there are so many
candidates this time around,
we want to filter out
by only candidates that
got at least 8,000 donations
and at least 5,000 donations
in a month.
So then I just ran that query.
It took eight seconds.
And here's the results.
But we want to make
a nice visualization.
So I'm opening up the
Re:dash visualization editor.
We can use a bar chart
with the x column month.
And the y column we
want just amount.
And then we group
it by recipient.
And here we are.
So we can see that, at
the beginning of 2015,
it was Hillary Clinton was
getting by far the most
donations.
And then fast
forward out to March,
Bernie Sanders actually
eclipsed Hillary
in the dollar
amount of donations.
And we see that Ted
Cruz was increasing.
And one interesting thing
you might want to note
is Donald Trump is this
little tiny line here.
Donald Trump was essentially
self-financing his election.
So he's not really taking in
much in the way of donations.
FELIPE HOFFA: Until now.
JORDAN TIGANI: Until now.
FELIPE HOFFA: But now, if we
wanted to jump to the past,
if we wanted to
see what happened
to Howard Dean, the story you
were mentioning earlier today,
how do you load this data?
How do you bring
it into BigQuery?
JORDAN TIGANI: Sure,
so the OpenSecrets data
that we have that we were able
to make public, was just 2016.
So if we want to look
at historical elections,
we have to use the
data that we've
downloaded from the Federal
Election Commission.
And this is what their
download page looks like.
And I've downloaded that data.
And I've uploaded it to
Google Cloud Storage.
And I'm using a
feature on BigQuery
called federated tables, which
means that the table doesn't
live in BigQuery.
It lives in some
external data source.
In this case, it's
Cloud Storage.
So it's going to go over all
of the individual donations.
It's going to read them as CSV.
And it's a slightly
weird format.
And because it's a
slightly weird format,
the donations don't tell
you who you're donating to.
It just tells you the
code of the committee
you're donating to.
So you have to join
against the committee.
And then you have to
join the committee
against the candidate.
So I've just done a
bunch of that work
and written that
to a summary table.
And this is the
summary table that
shows the candidate,
who gave the money,
and how much they gave.
And that table is 2
and 1/2 gigabytes.
And that's everything
from 1980 until the most
recent elections.
Now let's look at the
Howard Dean moment.
So I'm going to run
over that summary table
that I built. And we're going
to look for candidate Howard
Dean and John
Kerry, because those
were the two Democratic
frontrunners at the time.
And the time range
we're going to use
is between the end of 2003
to the beginning of 2004.
And I'm not going to show you
building this visualization
because it was
just, essentially,
the same as the
last one except we
select line chart
instead of bar chart.
And so you can see, this is the
numbers of donations per week.
And Howard Dean is
really just crushing it.
You see, like
December 31, I guess
everybody gets
their donation in,
so they can give more next year.
But January 19 here, the
date of the Dean scream,
it's interesting.
His supporters were
still supporting him.
He was still getting
donations after that.
But this really
gave his opponent
a lot more ammunition, realized
that he was vulnerable.
And people realize,
hey, I'm going
to give to this other guy.
FELIPE HOFFA: Wow.
That's how you can jump to
the past, go to any moment.
There's a lot of SQL here.
I don't know who knows SQL here?
SQL?
Yes, my kind of people.
But not everyone.
So what kind of
tools would you use
to use this same data to
explore it other ways,
without a line of SQL?
JORDAN TIGANI: Let's see.
So this is Tableau.
Tableau is a business
intelligence visualization
tool.
And Tableau has built-in
support for BigQuery.
So I'm going to connect
to BigQuery from Tableau.
And I'm going to connect to
the-- so I look at my project,
fill out my campaign
funding data set.
And I'm going to use
this summary table,
drag it over here.
Tableau goes and looks up
the schema, cardinality,
which types of fields they are.
And then I can build a new
visualization with this.
And so all I have to do is just
start dragging and dropping.
So I'm going to
drop amount to rows
because we're looking at rows.
And then, of course,
that's not very interesting
because it just sums
up all the rows.
But let's then use columns
as candidate affiliations.
So we can see how much
money has been given
to various political parties.
And of course, there's
lots of political parties.
But in the US, the Democratic
Party and the Republican Party
get all of the donations.
And this is really disturbing
because this-- oh, here we go.
That looks better.
So this is a visualization.
I basically just
took the same table
and just did a little
more dragging and dropping
that I won't do up here.
But this is showing
the amount of money
that is donated by
state, whether they
give more to Republicans
or more to Democrats.
And we can actually, we
can go year by year here.
So let's look at 2008.
Come on.
2008, there we go, the year
of Obama's first candidacy.
You can see that
coasts are very blue.
The center of the
country is red.
They're giving more
to Republicans.
But there's a smattering of
blue throughout the country.
Then, if you look
at the re-election,
the things had
solidified, really,
in the center of the country.
And basically, they're
giving very heavily
to the Republican side.
FELIPE HOFFA: Interesting.
Back to 2016, how are our
candidates doing so far?
Primaries.
JORDAN TIGANI: OK, well,
I don't know if people
are following the primaries.
But they're changing a lot.
There's a bunch of
these primaries.
So we have a Google
spreadsheet that
has the winners of each
primary, and the amount of votes
and delegates for each primary.
And so when you use a
feature of BigQuery--
this is also federated
tables-- but we
have a table here that's backed
by this Google spreadsheet.
So you can see the
format is Google Sheets.
And so I can run a query
to see who is winning.
And Hillary Clinton has the most
total votes, followed not too
far behind by Donald Trump.
But one of the cool
things about this
is you can modify
it in real time.
So let's stuff the
ballot box for Felipe.
FELIPE HOFFA: Thank you.
Thank you all.
[LAUGHTER]
JORDAN TIGANI: And
then rerun this query.
Now sometimes these
queries take a few seconds
because it's not really
optimized for fast access.
But hey!
[APPLAUSE]
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
People that use BigQuery
know how cool this is.
Yes, so that's
awesome new feature.
Please enjoy it.
Now let's start
connecting the dots.
These candidates are
collecting a lot of money.
They are spending money.
They are getting
votes, delegates.
Who's the most
efficient of these?
JORDAN TIGANI: Sorry,
I'm trying to remember
if we have a query for this.
Oh yes, we do have
a query for this.
So this query is going to
operate over the OpenSecrets
data set again.
And we are just going to sum
up the amount of donations.
But then we're going to join
it against the-- there we
go-- the primary results table.
So we can see how much money
these people are spending--
so this is actually the spending
side of things-- per vote
that they get.
And so we see that Ben Carson
was spending the most when
he was in the election.
He was spending the
most amount per vote,
followed by Hillary Clinton.
And of the remaining
major candidates,
Bernie Sanders has been
the most efficient.
I take Donald Trump out of
that just because Donald Trump
is not actually really
running his campaign
based on donations.
FELIPE HOFFA: And what's
super interesting here
is when we start looking
at these efficiencies,
is that we start wondering why?
How can one candidate be more
efficient than the other?
What's driving the results?
At least in the old
times, we could say TV.
This is the number of
mentions each candidate is
getting on TV so far,
measured by GDELT
using the internet archive.
And you can see that
Donald Trump is getting
way more mentions from TV.
That's a pretty nice
way to get votes
without spending a lot of money.
Followed by Clinton,
followed by Sanders,
and then everyone else.
And what's interesting
here is that, OK,
TV is working for
Trump very well.
But Sanders is getting pretty
efficient without getting
many TV mentions.
And we may wonder why.
And that's where our
next challenges go.
Let's go to old media
versus the new media.
We're going to incorporate
new tools, like Dataflow.
JORDAN TIGANI: So
Google Cloud Dataflow
is a batch and streaming
data processing
system, sort of like MapReduce,
but lets you operate it
at a much higher level.
And we're using Dataflow
to take Twitter data.
We're bringing it in.
We're transforming the data.
And we're writing it to pub/sub
and to a BigQuery table.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
JORDAN TIGANI: And then we're
also going to pull in the data
from pub/sub and put
it into Firebase.
And you guys have probably
heard a lot about Firebase
this week, so I don't have
to go into too much detail.
FELIPE HOFFA: So, OK,
let's start with old media.
Let's look at GDELT, all
the news in the world.
How old is the
worldwide media talking
about the US candidates?
JORDAN TIGANI: All right.
So we're going to use--
so the last visualization
Felipe showed of the
television efficiency, that
used the GDELT data set.
So we have the GDELT
data set in BigQuery.
But the GDELT data
set has a lot of data.
It has the emotional content
of every media article.
It has all of the
people who are mentioned
in it and the positions
within the article
that they mentioned.
But it can be a little bit
hard to query that using SQL.
So I'm using another
BigQuery feature here
called user defined functions.
And user defined functions allow
you to write JavaScript code
and have those run
inside your query.
So what I'm doing is, so, for
example, I'm trying to figure,
for articles that mention
political candidates, which
one are they really which one
are they really talking about.
Because a lot of articles about
Clinton also talk about Bernie.
But the article
is about Clinton.
So we have a code that
splits out some of these.
It's about 200 lines
of JavaScript code.
And then we can run this
directly in BigQuery.
So I've created a
view that uses this.
And sorry.
Sorry.
Ah, details, there we go.
And the query basically
just feeds the source data.
This is the raw GDELT table.
And then I can switch
back to Re:dash.
And we can run this query.
And this query usually
takes about a minute.
I'm going to hope
that it's fast today.
And, uh oh.
FELIPE HOFFA: Ooh.
We can come back here if it--
oh, we have a [INAUDIBLE] one.
JORDAN TIGANI: All right.
I'm going to skip to the
final visualization there.
But I'll show what, I think I
must have just typed something
into the box and
it screwed it up.
But so we're going to
show the emotional content
of these articles.
And so this can be either
positive or negative.
And for the major political
candidates-- or, sorry,
for just Hillary Clinton
and Donald Trump.
And we're going to split
those out by country.
And so we do a
join based on where
the media source comes from.
And then we are going to
map that to the article.
So what we can see-- and
so here's the result.
Of countries that
are writing articles
that mention US candidates,
this is with a positive
versus negative tone.
And one thing we
should note is, we
moved the average a
little bit to basically
be the overall average because,
overall, they were pretty
negative about both candidates.
So we're sort of
resetting the zero.
But so the highest
positive is Turkey.
I guess Turkey really
likes Hillary Clinton.
The highest negative
is Switzerland.
The Swiss are not big
Donald Trump fans.
Maybe he doesn't
use their banks.
[LAUGHTER]
JORDAN TIGANI: And so
you might ask, well,
can you guys plot this on a map?
Maybe Felipe was
about to ask me that.
But we don't have to.
Somebody already did.
So [INAUDIBLE], someone
who's done a lot of BigQuery
queries, and that we've
worked with in the past,
he plotted these in CartoDB.
And so this is sort
of the map version
of which countries are
positive and negative
about Hillary Clinton.
And here's the same
for Donald Trump.
FELIPE HOFFA: Russia
really has a positive tone,
those articles.
JORDAN TIGANI: As does Ukraine.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
So it's really cool to be able
to look up the worldwide media,
join it with where the
source of that media comes,
join it, look at tone, and start
analyzing what happened there.
Let's go back to Bernie.
Where was the first place
you heard about Bernie?
Was it TV?
Was it the media?
Was it Reddit?
JORDAN TIGANI: I feel like
social media picked up
on Bernie Sanders before
the mainstream media.
FELIPE HOFFA: How can you
show me that with data?
JORDAN TIGANI: All right.
Well, let's check this out.
So this is a query that is
going to combine multiple data
sources together.
So this is going to
combine the GDELT data set.
This was the view that
I created earlier.
We're also going to look
at all Reddit comments.
So we're going to also look at
candidate popularity in Reddit
comments.
Then we're going to look
at Wikipedia page views.
So maybe people were looking at
the candidate's web page a lot
and see when see
when those picked up.
And then we're computing
a trailing average
so that the numbers don't
bounce up and down too much.
Beautiful.
Maybe I can reload this page.
Just to give an idea of
how big this query is?
This query is a 5.24 terabytes.
FELIPE HOFFA: So that's of data.
JORDAN TIGANI: So
that's a lot of data.
It takes about a minute.
And you know, there's
a lot of stuff
that has to-- we're running
a user defined function
over billions of
entries in GDELT. We're
taking these multiple data
sources from different places.
And so here's what the
visualization looks like.
So we can see that, really,
the mainstream media and Reddit
and Wikipedia all really
picked up on the Bernie story
at about the same time.
So GDELT is a proxy for
the mainstream media.
Perhaps these peaks
were a bit higher
for Reddit and Wikipedia.
So maybe this is showing
that social media was
more devoted to Bernie Sanders.
And then certainly,
this Reddit line
has stayed higher for most of
the timeframe that we have.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
It seems that people really
enjoy when we mentioned Reddit.
Yes?
Let's look at what people
are talking in Reddit about.
Are they talking about
Clinton, Sanders, Trump?
JORDAN TIGANI: All right.
So we'll basically look
over all comments in Reddit
and run a query that figures out
how many authors are commenting
about these candidates.
And the query is not
all that interesting.
Let me just see if--
yeah, we're just
filtering by the phrases Donald
Trump, Hillary Clinton, Bernie
Sanders.
And then we can see what
the timeline looks like.
FELIPE HOFFA: So we
can see that there
are more authors talking about
Bernie Sanders than Trump,
than Clinton.
And that's just how Reddit goes.
JORDAN TIGANI: So not everybody
uses the full name Bernie
Sanders.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's
a good question.
JORDAN TIGANI: So they could
just say Bernie, or Hillary,
or-- I think just Trump.
Even though the subreddit
for Donald Trump
is called The Donald,
so maybe in that he gets
called just Donald more often.
But one of the nice things
about this in BigQuery
is it's easy to
change your mind.
It's easy to just run
a different query.
And hopefully this
will be fast today.
FELIPE HOFFA: How long
does it take to analyze
all of Reddit comments?
JORDAN TIGANI: So it should
take only a few seconds.
But--
FELIPE HOFFA: How
fast is our network?
JORDAN TIGANI: I'm not going
blame it on the network today.
I will own this.
I'll switch back if it doesn't
finish in the next five
seconds.
Two-- all right.
We can jump to something else.
Here we go!
Five seconds.
It knew.
So it looks about
the same, actually.
But I think the numbers
are much higher.
FELIPE HOFFA: 56,000
authors talking about Trump?
That's a lot of Redditors.
But then it's hard to know if
they are talking positively
about Trump, negatively.
But there are some
subreddits that
are dedicated to
each candidate--
Sanders for President, The
Donald, Hillary Clinton.
Each has their own
group of subredditors
that have different
behaviors, different likes.
And a very interesting
question I have there
is, where were the
supporters four years ago
for the previous election?
JORDAN TIGANI: So what we
can do is, for this one,
we're going to look
at the subreddits that
are devoted, the Reddit
spaces that are devoted
to particular candidates.
In this case, it's Sanders
for President, The Donald,
and Hillary Clinton.
And then we're going to
join it against history.
So we're pulling out authors.
And they we're joining
against history
to figure out, what are
these authors posting
in four years ago, in 2012?
What were they up to before they
started talking about politics?
FELIPE HOFFA: Any guess?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JORDAN TIGANI: So the
Sanders supporters
were talking about space
and Occupy Wall Street.
Occupy Wall Street
kind of makes sense.
Trump supporters were talking
about guns and Ron Paul.
[LAUGHTER]
And I think there's
one that's interesting,
is then the Hillary supporters
are basically Enough Ron Paul.
They had it with Ron Paul.
So I think it was already
setting up the Hillary versus
Donald for the [INAUDIBLE].
FELIPE HOFFA: I love being
able to find these things.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Back to real time.
Back to what's
happening right now.
Last 60 seconds.
What are people
talking about now?
JORDAN TIGANI: All right.
So actually in
the last campaign,
one of the things that the
candidates really started doing
is they started monitoring
Twitter in real time.
So they would notice, hey, the
candidate made a statement.
What did Twitter think of it?
And they could use that
to shape their message
and how their message
was getting out
to their supporters.
So we have a Twitter feed
that is running a Google Cloud
Dataflow.
And we're pulling out anything
that mentions the candidates.
And we're writing
it to two places.
One is we're streaming
into a BigQuery table.
And the other one
is we're writing it
to the Cloud pub/sub.
And I'm going to jump to-- we
have a really simple server
that is in JavaScript--
only 100 lines of code--
that's going to
read from pub/sub.
And it's going to
write it to Firebase.
And this is just sort of
the logging of the IDs
of these Tweets, but so
really, really simple.
We also have a
very small website
that's going to create
a dashboard for us.
And we'll allow that.
So let me jump back to--
So here's the
Firebase output here.
We can see that
we're writing tweets.
And then here's our dashboard.
So the dashboard is basically
just pulling up the latest
tweet and displaying it here.
And we can also see the
hashtags that show up
most often with the candidates.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
We have no idea what tweets
are being shown in real time.
So fingers crossed.
JORDAN TIGANI: So
it's always dangerous
when you try to show social
media in real time in a talk
because--
[LAUGHTER]
I won't even fill in the
rest of that statement.
FELIPE HOFFA: And what
kind of interesting things
can we do with these tweets?
JORDAN TIGANI: I mentioned
that the candidates
were using this in real time.
And so let's just look at the
things that have been tweeted,
the tweets that have been
done since this talk started.
So it's been about 30 minutes
since we have been here.
And so we can see that
there's been 31,000 tweets.
But that's not really
that impressive.
30 minutes is a long time.
So let's look at seconds.
FELIPE HOFFA: Second.
JORDAN TIGANI: Ah, thank you.
I'm an over-pluralizer.
What about the last 10 seconds?
How many tweets were
in the last 10 seconds?
Boom, so we have 45 tweets
in the last 10 seconds
that are already in BigQuery.
So this is from the time
when somebody posted this,
they hit Send on Twitter.
It's gone through
the Twitter API.
It's gone to pub/sub.
And then it's gone
through Dataflow.
And it's going into BigQuery.
And it's immediately query-able.
FELIPE HOFFA: Wow.
JORDAN TIGANI: So
let's try to look
at something like what the
candidates would want to do.
So I'm going to jump
back to Re:dash.
And so we're going to look at
the hashtags of things that
have been happening in
the last hour, things
that people have
been tweeting about,
that are in tweets
about the candidates.
And we're going to look and see
how that compares to yesterday.
So this will hopefully
show us what's
new, what things are trending
that weren't here yesterday.
So here is what we have.
We have people tweeting about
Trump and the second amendment,
but also Bernie.
That's sort of interesting.
I wonder if there was
some news about that.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's Clinton.
JORDAN TIGANI: What
interesting Clinton things?
Probably can't say
some of them on--
FELIPE HOFFA: Real
time data, sorry.
JORDAN TIGANI: Adopt-a-palooza,
that's-- anyway.
So yeah, real time.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes,
real time data.
JORDAN TIGANI: Social media
is always, always interesting.
FELIPE HOFFA: So we have
about nine minutes left.
Are we going to do this?
Are we?
JORDAN TIGANI:
Unfortunately-- we could,
but we are not going to
predict the next president.
But we didn't want
to get out of here
without showing some prediction.
After all, we did a reasonably
good job of that last time.
And Google has
these amazing tools
that you've probably
been hearing
about the last few days,
TensorFlow and Cloud Datalab.
FELIPE HOFFA: Those
are our tools.
TensorFlow, an open source
tool to run machine learning
algorithms.
Datalab, a pretty nice open
source notebook environment
to mix all of our
elements together.
So we're going to try to
predict who said what?
JORDAN TIGANI: That seems
like the safer thing to do.
FELIPE HOFFA: "Safer."
JORDAN TIGANI: So I'm going to
look at the data that we have.
And so we've gathered
some statements
from various candidates.
It's not a whole lot of data.
So we're going to build
a machine-learning model
with only 200K of data.
And I'll show you
what these look like.
These are just statements
that various candidates
have said that we've
collected from the media.
And we're going to use this.
And we're going to feed it
into a machine-learning model.
I'm going to build the
model while I'm talking.
So let me just run to this cell.
So this is Google Cloud Datalab.
This is the the iPython
or Jupiter notebook
for doing scientific computing.
And it has nice integration
with TensorFlow.
So this seems like a lot of
code, but most of this code
actually is just
manipulating the text.
So we're pulling this data
out of Google Cloud Storage.
And then we're
reading the data files
and splitting the data files.
That's actually
most of the code.
So this is really all
the TensorFlow code
that we need to do this.
Most of it is just
setting up outputs,
setting up what it
means to be right,
or we're trying to minimize
or maximize-- in this case,
it's the cross entropy.
And we're going to use an Ftrl
optimizer, which doesn't really
matter what that means.
It's an algorithm that's
used in Google for ads.
And it also has-- I
mean, you can essentially
use a lot of different
optimizers here.
But this one this one
works out pretty well.
And then we're going to
minimize the cross entropy
if we want to get,
basically, as close as
possible to the correct results.
And then this loop here
just runs the training.
So we can see the output of the
accuracy of this is about 72%.
So that may not
seem all that high.
But if you consider that
we had a human actually
try to figure out how well they
could do at categorizing these.
And the human only
got about 60%.
So we built a model
that can do better
than a human at identifying
these statements.
All right.
So now I have some quotes
from the various candidates.
And we can run
this model and see
if we can predict what
they're actually saying.
And these quotes were not
part of the training set.
And so these are
things, basically,
just from their website.
So let's see-- lovely.
There we go.
So predicted Clinton,
actually Clinton.
FELIPE HOFFA: We will totally
dismantle Iran's global terror
network.
TensorFlow [INAUDIBLE].
What my campaign is about
is a political revolution.
Millions of people are
standing up and saying,
enough is enough.
Our government
belongs to all of us
and not just a handful
of billionaires.
Who said that?
JORDAN TIGANI: Bernie Sanders.
FELIPE HOFFA: It knows.
You can read the Cruz one.
JORDAN TIGANI: We need
a commander-in-chief
who will prioritize US
national security interests.
And that one was Ted Cruz.
FELIPE HOFFA: And
that's pretty good.
JORDAN TIGANI: So
here's something
that I don't think any
candidates have said.
FELIPE HOFFA: Trying something
that they never said.
JORDAN TIGANI: But does
anybody have a suggestion
of a statement they want us to
try to guess which candidate
would be more likely to say it?
FELIPE HOFFA: Any
random statement?
Just to try it out?
JORDAN TIGANI: Anyone?
AUDIENCE: TensorFlow is great.
We love TensorFlow.
JORDAN TIGANI: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
FELIPE HOFFA: We
love TensorFlow.
OK, we're running
out of time now.
JORDAN TIGANI: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Time
to close this talk.
I hope you were entertained.
But this is not only
about data, not only
about how we analyze
and entertain ourselves,
is how we use the
different Google Cloud
tools-- TensorFlow, Datalab,
BigQuery, of course--
and how we connect
different data sets,
how we draw lines
between these points.
Take these tools and bring
them to our world, how
we can change where we live?
We can vote, to start with.
Well, not everyone can vote.
But we still can be
part of the process.
JORDAN TIGANI: And, you know,
these elections are important.
And we hope that these
tools that we built
will inspire you to
say, hey, I can do that.
That's easy.
Inspire you to actually
go out, and try them,
and change the world.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
And thank you to everyone
that helped us run
these demos, Reddit, Twitter.
JORDAN TIGANI: We had
from the Dataflow team,
Sam [? McVeedy ?], [? Sarah ?]
Robinson helped with
the Firebase.
[INAUDIBLE] team helped
with the TensorFlow.
Lots of people we're
probably forgetting.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes,
Re:dash, also, yes.
JORDAN TIGANI: Re:dash, yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
A big thanks to
developer advocates,
everyone that makes I/O happen.
And if nothing else
works, there are so
many other things we can do.
We can be back in two years to
talk about the World Cup again.
Thank you very much.
JORDAN TIGANI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]